no i think it's just like a
it's a place that's fine
what else is going on how's your girl uh
she's good
are you guys gonna get married before
bobby and i
probably yeah
unless unless you're gonna propose at
the house no we don't do proposals it's
going to be one of those shotgun i might
as well you think bobby's not going to
propose no where i feel like we've had
this talk before and this is what bobby
says he's like babe i just don't know
how to do it
he goes do i call abby
and if i ask you yeah and you say no
i would never say i know but if you said
no to me and i asked you
that would that would scar me for all of
life
that's worse than the dog
of a nightmare my whole life i never
wanted easy yeah what kind of guys do
you like
i
i didn't think i could get
the type of
the inspiration
the two worlds
i like them fat and wild
i've always dreamt of a man i said i
need i need a fat and wild man and
that's honestly a good album when i do
what no when i do us special
that's the title
fat and wild
yeah i love that yeah yeah i love it and
that was always my first instinct when i
first moved to america
my first boyfriend
josh he wrote a bmx he was fat and wild
and then as my hair grew out and i took
my braces out all of a sudden i shifted
and i got cuter boys but then i had to
go back home yeah where the fat and
wilds were yeah yeah
it really is an interesting um
person to be
being fat and wild
you know
because you
you can surprise people
like if they don't know who i am yeah
right
and i walk into
a nightclub
they're gonna see some [ __ ]
like
dancing they've never seen before me
disappear reappear
um if especially when i'm using doing
drugs oh be careful i'd blow everyone
fat wow crazy yeah
you know what i mean yeah eat [ __ ]
too oh one [ __ ] just one but blow a lot
i blow everyone blow everyone but just
one closer yeah
um
i have some um rumors but i can't say it
damn it
but i want to throw it out there you
know what they are called yeah i know
what it is
i'll tell you what it is i'm gonna tell
you okay i
the gist of it all right so
sanzo i'm gonna give you a just
and no one's gonna know but here's some
clues okay